I hate this
your son will kill you that's a fact
scientific fact there's nothing coming
out of the Sun except molten death
absolutely purely because of water
tickets at one of over Jungle Girl
all the son does is suck every ounce of
water out of your entire body if you
were out in the Sun for too long
you would die that's just a fact it's
full of radiation it literally blasts
your DNA in half and I ain't about that
I want to live but we got ways to
beat who heat other than just fixing the
air-conditioner I didn't get strings
what just moved you okay all right
here's the situation
son no good so we gotta find a way to
beat this son and we've already solved
half the problem we got a van
it's got shade it's got air conditioning
and it's got a convenient power hookup
this bad boy is practically a mobile
generator and if we fix it up with the
right things then we'll would have
was an eraser no that's just a magnet so
what do I need I need a few simple
things I need chica I need some good
old-fashioned water just just a bit of
oxygen not a lot but just a bit and I
need a way to play some video games
because if I don't have video games I
don't know how to video games there we
go that's a G and if in order to give
video games what do you need it out oh
yes very good so when you want to play
video games you need the TV and what
else cheek what else what else do we
need pop up there dog dog I got that
check that off the list and also you
need fuel oh you need fuel fuel stands
for fridge under electric load video
game stands for very in debt eeeek oh
god a man-eating spider TV stands for
television so now that we've gone over
the acronyms but in the little now we
know what you need to do but there's one
thing that we can't get right now and
that's internet so we got to make do
with old school back when I was a kid we
that's back when I was a kid we didn't
even have the internet for our concepts
consoles didn't even have an Internet
book up hook up hook up consoles didn't
even have the Jackie port you slam into
the
you know so we need to get a fridge and
where do we get a fridge I don't either
so we're gonna ask hi-ho silver oh ah
bicyclists and follow them or if they're
gonna lead me back to their bike nest
you know bikers are the most elite full
of all predators number one number four
number whatever that number is
whew we gotta get a fridge and in order
to get a fridge
we either would go to a store and buy a
mini fridge which is or booze
or what I drop my head there's someone
that has a fridge and I'm willing to pay
for it
pay for the van pay for a bridge if it's
got some kind of like wood finish a
barrel frigate barrel
you gotta get a barrelful we're not buy
a barrel for the barrel will come to you
what could go wrong here then fix and
the bow and tweet it okay
so now this should be fine right my fans
know that I don't goofed them so the
responses must be absolutely 100%
serious zip for freezing body parts why
it's a mini fridge what kind of body
parts would I be freezing in a mini
fridge it's not a mini freezer what the
fresh hell are you doing fridge first a
van now a fridge you're a madman
truly the scariest thing about marks
return from hiatus Issac on fridge
everything
ah people have trust issues
no no why we got other options and we
can let that brew for a bit so if they
come back to me and I get their heads
out of their asses maybe now what we're
looking I've got a response that seems
legit hey Mark I do have a mini-fridge
that is in good working condition and I
do live in LA it looks well loved to do
it's like it doesn't come with the stand
do that alright okay I'm gonna send a
message hey that looks pretty good
I'm sending you a video so you know it's
me and not someone crazy it didn't sound
suspicious at all did it yeah probably
about 45 minutes away all right so we're
about five minutes away not only do they
have a fridge but they also got a TV
that's gonna be perfect because his
combo TV VCR and everybody knows that my
favorite movie is flubber on VCR because
when I was a kid I watched it so much
that the VCR at the v8 BDA the VHS bb-8
AAA the VHS tape broke and then I never
got to see it again so after I go to
Cracker Barrel I'm watching flubber or
on the way there I'm watching flubber
and trying to drive at the same time I'm
thinking I can found the TV like right
here
I think we're here oh oh hi hello
approach the conspicuous suspicious
white van
how you doing it yeah hello what's your
name
Ileana it's nice to meet you Ileana
yeah how are you doing great yeah so you
have a mini-fridge Anna TV okay
so let's thank you so much everyone else
didn't believe us yeah I figured I don't
know why the Internet's full of energy
theorists all right yeah so thanks so
much for responding leg is super cool oh
yeah right there when we were thinking
we thought we were gonna have to go to
like thrift stores or whatever but hey
it's touching eyesight is working
oh I heard you have guavas no I won't
take all of what digger like a copy of
you if a hundred is ok for so strong
this is serendipity to be sure yeah
there you go
total nutrients on the road Thank You
Man appreciate it
diagonally oh yeah oh that's oh that's
money right there
Oh
[Music]
it's so perfect I'm so perfect
does the VHS work oh your belief is all
I need yes we'll come find you boss
compare gun holy look at this look
at that sorry look at this you go look
at this damn Oh smells like guava and
pumpkin back here she could use a good
girl who's a good girl now where was
that hot come on back here give me a
hand with this these are mounted on
something
and got to breakfast some grip some gas
I'm an engineer I should be able to
figure this out right that's not gonna
do anything
yeah I've got a big brain yes I do I've
got appropriate is true food Nellie look
unless we'd like flipped I don't think
we're good yeah as my great-grand papi
once said good enough let's get a beer
oh it's so hot over here
ah my hand is melting ah it's so hot
what's it so hot what do I have huh
there's something goopy I don't like
that here we go okay got it
oh thanks for the help turn that on I'm
fine don't worry about me oh oh never
considered the fact that there might not
be enough power from
well alright then look who's got a TV
yeah
that's creepy as hell hop back up where
it's not soon yeah we did what we came
out to do we got a phrase we got TV
we're well on our way to turning this
into a livable situation so that we
don't have to be in the horrible outside
where the Sun will kill you cuz it will
I promise you ow just sprayed my head on
that so we got as you can see from a
bird from a very distinct list here
we've got how did it again we got dog TV
fuel all this left is a video games but
we need to solve a bigger power problem
that I don't think we're gonna get to
today I think we need to take our
victories where it counts but it's a
pretty good day so thank you so much for
jokes
thank you so much for joining me and as
always see you in the next video bye